ねえ、それはドゲンですええと、私は1989年8月3日生まれのレオです
。
私はユーチューバーで、自由な時間に
バスケットボールをしたり映画を見たりするのが好き
です。
私は小道具と衣装のメーカーであり
、ビデオ編集者でもあり
ます。自由時間に
は、仮面ライダースーパー戦隊ウルトラマンのような特撮番組を見るのが好きです。
私の犬
[音楽]
こんにちは私の名前はキャシーです。 私は
アメリカのフロリダ出身で、
27歳です。
こんにちは。私の名前はフランス語で、日本に住んでいます。
[音楽]
こんにちは、私はelleryです。私は18歳です。
言語学の学位取得に向けて取り組んでいます
こんにちは私の名前はザビエルですええと
水族館2001年1月25日生まれの
私の自由な時間に私は
あなたに会えてうれしいゲームをするのが好きです
何年も
こんにちは私の名前は光です私はフランス
人で2年間日本に住んでいます
[音楽]
こんにちはみんな私の 名前はアリです。私は
メキシコから来て、日本に
1年います。
ホラコミスタンソヤ
[音楽]
ねえみんな私の名前のコディ私は25歳
で、趣味は音楽を演奏しています
[音楽]
こんにちは皆さん私の名前はマークです 私は
ここ日本に住んでいるフィリピン人です
こんにちは私の名前はジェラルドです私は
スペイン
出身です私は1996年12月に生まれました
私はビデオ編集者ですそして私はほぼ2年間
日本語を勉強しています
私は20歳で、ドイツ出身です。
こんにちは。私の名前はannika ichbinswanseです。ここuncommonsdeutschlandです。
こんにちは。私の名前はandyです
。私は1997年9月8日に生まれたバーゴです。
m
[音楽]
日本で英語の先生になることを学ぶ
音楽
[音楽]
こんにちは私の名前はショーンです私はジェミニです私は
ゼロという名前の犬を飼っています
日本の学生で
、高校生から日本語を勉強してい
ます。はじめまして、私の名前はアカネです。私はカナダ人です。
私は通訳大学の講師
で、
剣道をやっています。趣味はこんにちは。
こんにちは。
こんにちは。私の名前は21
歳です。マレーシアに住んでいて、現在
日本で勉強しています。
[音楽]
um
土地
[音楽]
ツイッターでこのことが起こっているのを見
て、英語で紹介してみませんか。
私の名前はサラ
です。私は36歳で、カナダから来ました。
今は日本人です。
こんにちは私の名前はスライマンです。
名前のブランドン私は31歳
で、州に住んでいて
、YouTubeチャンネルを運営しています。
こんにちは。私の名前は28歳です。
私はレオです。今は営業活動をしています
。趣味は今、文学です。
たくさんのモダニズムを読んでたくさんの
バージニアウールフ
私もハイキングを楽しんでいるので、私
と共有したいスポットを見つけたら
、私に知らせて
ください
こんにちは私は黒檀です私は日本に住んでいます '
ここに10年います
私は音楽とエンターテインメントで働いています
こんにちは私の名前はアンジェラです私は31歳
です私はイタリア人です オランダに住んでいます
こんにちは
オランダ
私は犬が好きで家族が大好きです
こんにちは私の名前はユヤです私は日本人です私は
大学生
です私は22歳
です1989年私はユーチューブで自由な時間に